[音楽]
私の小学校2年生の時の将来の夢は
公認会計士でした
皆さん思い出してみてください
小学校にニュースへ8歳の時
公認会計士
でどんな言葉か知っていたでしょうか
小学校2年生でこういう感じですちょっと
歯が抜けててあどけない感じで
当時の私なんですが
こんな幼い顔をした8歳の時の私は
もちろん
公認会計士がなんたる職業かなんて全然
知りませんでした
でもそれが私の将来の夢だったんです
それが私のお父さんが私になってほしい
職業だったからです
私は高校2年生になりました
まだ将来の夢は公認会計士でした
いや
夢ではありませんでした
自分が本当に公認会計士になりたいとは
ちっとも思えませんでした
でもお父さんから生まれた言葉
公認会計士は資格職で女性が活躍できる
職業なんだよ
子供ができても一生働いていける
この言葉を信じた私は公認会計士が女性に
とって一番働きやすい職業なのだと思って
いたんです
俺も高校2年生
進路のこと将来のことを友達と話す中で
だんだん疑問を抱き始めました
学校の先生になりたい
災難になりたい
そうやって将来のことを話す友達の目は
もうキラキラしていて私はものすごく
羨ましく思いました
私はそんな彼がや痛みをして公認会計士に
なりたいなんて言えない
どうして私は興味のない職業になろうとし
ているんだろう
その片方はたった一つでした
女性として働きやすいから
でもそもそもんを生んで女性だからって
働きやすさを重視しないといけないん
だろう
どうして結婚したら子供ができたら働き
にくくなるんだろう
どうして私は女性だからといってなりたく
もない職業が将来の夢だなんて嘘ついて
いるんだろう
その時高校生ながらに思ったんです
私のこの悩みの根本の原因は私のお父さん
ではありません
育児や介護など自分のプライベートを大事
にしながら働ける社会であればそもそも
学生がこんな悩みを持つことはないかも
しれないと
そう考えた私はワークライフバランスを
学ぼうと決意し大学2年生の時北欧
スウェーデンに長期留学をしました
スウェーデンという国は共働きで子育てを
する家庭が多いと有名です
夫婦ともに働き一緒に子育てをして3時半
ごろに子供を迎えに行って東風頃には家族
全員で夕飯を食べるという日本では
なかなか見られないような風景が当たり前
の社会です
そんなスウェーデンで私は育児をする
お母さんお父さん
会社の神乳の形大学の先生などいろんな
立場の30人以上の方にインタビューを
行いました
まずはそこから見つけた
スウェーデンのようにプライベートを大事
にできる社会
を作るために私たち一人ひとりができる
ことを3つお話ししたいと思います
プライベートな時間は不便さと引き換えだ
と理解し
広めること
スウェーデンはとても不便でした
例えば一度日本から郵便を送ってもらい
郵便局留めにした際にえーっ受け取りの
時間が平日のお昼2時間だけだったことが
ありました
2時間です働いている人はどうやって
受け取ればいいの2色
女が労働時間を減らしプライベートな時間
を確保すればその分社会のサービス機能は
低下します
でもそれをよしとしてきたのが
スウェーデンの人たちです
みんながか切られた労働時間の中で社会を
回すから不便でも仕方がない
そう受け入れるからこそ残業時間が少ない
社会構造になっています
もし私たち日本人ももっと
プライベードの時間を確保した犬なら同じ
ように不便さに寛容になる必要がある
でしょう
だから少しずつでいい
あなたの周りに広めてくれたらとても
嬉しいです
例えば友達とレストランに行ったとします
日曜日なのに不定休でしまっていた
もし友達が日曜日なのに開いてないのか
なんて不満げだったりしたら行ってみて
ください
まあしょうがないよね
店員さんだって休みが欲しいもねあ
少しずつ少しずつ
不便さに寛容の人が広がればまわりまわっ
てあなた自身もプライベートを大事に
できる環境を作れるかもしれません
2点目
家事のハードルを下げること
皆さん私たち日本人はめちゃくちゃ火事
頑張ってます家事をされている方誇りを
持ってください本当にすごいです
私はスウェーデンで現地の家庭に
ホームステイをしました
驚いたのは料理の仕方です
山盛りのご飯にメインが逸品そして毎日
同じサラダその3つを1人ずつワン
プレートにもって食べます
そして食べ終わったら食器を大きな大きな
食洗機に入れ柄に1回だけ回します
この写真はスウェーデンの伝統的な家庭
料理ですがこんな風にワンプレートに盛る
ことでお空の数が格段に減りお皿洗いが
とても楽になるんです
一方で日本の和食はこんな感じで食器の数
が多くてちょっとお空雷が大変ですよね
私は日本の和食が大好きなのでその文化を
なくそうなどというつもりは全く持ってい
ません
でも疲れているとき
忙しい時くらいには細かい食器を使ったり
一汁三菜頑張って造らなくたって
ワンプレートに盛り付けたっていいんじゃ
ないかなって思うんです
えむしろ
お子様ランチみたいで小さなお子さんは
喜ぶかもしれません
家事を手抜きするという表現だと悪い印象
になるかもしれませんが
そもそも私たち日本人の家事はやることが
多いのですから
手抜きせるというよりむしろ
ハードルを下げる
という風に考えてみてはどうでしょうか
忙しい中で自分の時間を確保するために
少しでもこの考え方が役に立つととても
嬉しいです
そして三つ目
意見を言いやすい職場をつくるかと
スウェーデンの職場はフラットで上下関係
がないとよく言われています
例えば会社で部下が上司に対して
この仕事を本当に必要なんですか
こっちの方がもっと犬せんじゃないですか
当たり前にいう雰囲気があったりするそう
です
みんなが気になったことをすぐに口に出す
からいらない作業が日常的にカットされ
仕事が効率的になる
それが残業せずとも仕事が回る一つの理由
だとのこと
日本のとある働き方コンサルタントの方が
働き方を改善するコンサルティングの方法
は社員を集めて日
日々のモヤモヤを発散してもらうことだと
言っていました
これを考えるとスウェーデンでは
コンサルタントが入らずとも元から
モヤモヤを言えるからこそ効率よく働く
ことができるのでしょう
それなら日本でも上下関係なくもや模様
言える雰囲気であれば残業を減らす方法が
見つかるのではないでしょうか
まだ社会の現場を知らない学生の
甘っちょろい考えかもしれません
でも話しやすい雰囲気を作るためであれば
小さな工夫からできるはず
例えば会社の同僚とモヤモヤを話し合う
時間を取ってみてはどうでしょうか
まだ入社したばかりで自分ではできない
場合でも意見を聞いてくれる上司に提案
することはできるでしょう
小さなことから少しずつ
何でも言える雰囲気の職場を作れば
おのずと仕事は効率化されていくはずです
この3つのハウてー
私たち一人ひとりが小さなことから始めれ
ばこの日本においても少しずつ
プライベートを大事にできる環境を作れる
かもしれません
しかし
一つ
問いを投げかけたいと思います
ワークライフバランス
て
ただプライベートを大事にできること
だけでしょうか
スウェーデンで育児と仕事を両立する一人
の女性にインタビューをした時にある衝撃
的なお話を伺いました
それは
ワークライフバランスを取ることへの
プレッシャー
がする入れにはあるというお話です
というのは夫婦は普通魂働きで子育てをし
て3時半ごろに子供を迎えに行って5時頃
に家族全員で夕飯を食べる
という術でにとって当たり前のワーク
ライフバランスの形を守らなければいけ
ない
というプレッシャーです
っつ
例えばその方の知り合いに5人の子供を
育てる専業主婦の方がいたとのこと
5人の子供を育てるってものすっごく
忙しくて大変な仕事です
でも可能車の周りには
辰平彼女は専業主婦だから
仕事をしていなかったら飾って立って戦前
できるんだよ
仕事をしていないことを少し蔑むように
話す人がいるそう
また弁護士としてとても忙しく働く
スウェーデン人のお母さんは3時半ごろに
子供を迎えに行ってご飯を食べさせてね
つけたあと夜遅い時間にわざわざ会社に
戻って仕事をするとのこと
それも早い時間に子供を迎えに行くべき
というプレッシャーからくるものです
みんなが働いて残業せずに帰って子育ても
両立するそれだけがワークライフバランス
でしょうか
専業節府や仕事を頑張りたくて頑張る人は
ワークライフバランスがとれていないの
でしょうか
この話を聞いたとき私は改めて思いました
本当に問題なのが
プライベートな時間をとれないことでは
ない
自分が自分の生きたいように自由に生きる
ことができないことなのだと
女性だから育児と両立しなきゃいけないだ
から続けられる仕事を選ばなきゃ
男性だから家族を支えないといけないだ
から給料の良い仕事を選ばなきゃ
もっとプライベートの時間を取りたいけど
て方が日探し来て休めない
まあ仕方がないか
日本ではこんな風に近いからの期待や
プレッシャーに影響されて自分の生きたい
ように生きられないことがしばしばあると
思います
でもそれはスウェーデンでも同じように
共働きで子育てをするのが当たり前だから
だから専業主婦はカッコ悪い仕事ばかりし
ている人の格好悪い
という社会の当たり前によって生き方が
影響されてしまうところがあると思うの
です
本当のワークライフバランスとはそうでは
なくて
自分自身が自分自身で自由にその生き方を
決められる
自分で決められる状態なのだと
私は思います
とは言え確かに日本はこれまであまりにも
仕事をする人にとってプライベートの時間
を大事にするのが難しい状況でした
だからまずはプライベートを大事にする
選択肢を作るそのために確かに働き方改革
は必要です
でもそれだけではなく専業主婦や仕事を
頑張り各て頑張る人の生き方も尊重できた
なら日本は本当の意味でのワークライフ
バランス大国になれるでしょう
普通にまとめました
まず私たち日本がいるところ仕事の比率が
大きくプライベートの時間が削られがちな
社会です
そしてスウェーデン
仕事場会ではなくプライベートの時間も
尊重される社会です
でも一方でそんなプレッシャーも感じたり
します
そしてさらにその先に本当のワークライフ
バランスが取れる社会
どんな生き方でも尊重される社会です
まずはスウェーデンのようにプライベート
を大事にできる選択肢を作るそのために3
つの方法をご紹介しました
でもそれだけではなく
いろいろの生き方を受け入れ
それぞれにワークライフバランスは異なる
のだということを頭の片隅に残しておく
こと
そうすることで本当の意味でのワーク
ライフバランス大国を作る一歩となる
でしょう
みなさんが自分自身で生きたいように生き
自分にとってのワークライフバランスを手
に入れることを切に願っています
ありがとうございました
[音楽]